so let's begin by getting one of the
biggest lies that I have ever told my
audience out of the way
today we're officially calling out -
detectives putting up the worst red
camera video that is on the Internet
unfortunately he just doesn't have a
good grasp of what makes the red camera
a good camera I also think he's making
those videos because complaining about
that sort of thing gets abused it's you
know it does reflect on his you know
personal opinion in his credibility as a
source of information pretty to bigger
skirt and totally worked this little
piece here didn't break off this time
this is on here like this is when I
found it something got fudged I don't
think I loaded the plastic filament
correctly and I want to try making a
mask I want to learn how to print
something like this out of something
like that I'm thinking of starting with
this Red Hood helmet I'm going to
disregard all his individual pieces here
and I'm going to take his full mask
model and recut it myself
hopefully not screw this whole thing up
so there you go this is about ten hours
into it who is horse made contact so I
got the big skirt that fixed the feeding
issue I think the support printed it
didn't get unstuck from the platform
sweet it worked
[Music]
[Applause]
all I heard was minecraft and then ah it
was sitting there the game was sit in
there because that's the only game you
play and I go I'm just gonna say it it's
minecraft and it goes got you eight one
two three four and five six those by six
ports come off actually really cleanly
no 3d print video on the seventy
co-channel would be complete without a
mention of matter hackers the other ones
who supplied us at the Ultimaker three
and they supplied us in this filament
you guys are looking to getting your own
3d printer or get in some filament or
anything else that's 3d printing related
go check them out just link in the
description below this is a 36-hour
print let's see how it turned out
forty-nine thousand five hundred US
dollars well you should be done it
should come with a lens a battery uh
we're lucky it has a freaking power
button yeah but it's it's also the thing
is is that what that does is it echoes
this idea of like alright what do I need
to play a lot of good video games and
like Oh take a take a 1080 graphics card
and you hold it you're like where's the
screen don't just give me a MacBook man
this this is a $100 card reader a
hundred dollars for a card reader they
can give you such a great deal $99.99 on
the reader is because they just bent you
over a barrel on the proprietary media
yeah I should have oriented a little bit
differently this is the front and I have
to handle this down here can these
supports dissolve in water like you know
these are breaking like they I bring
down the plastic useless yank it off no
ego is very weak
these two things I put the half mask on
come half the hood yes look at me from
this side it's like I'm the red hood and
now I'm just regular Nico I'm bad at all
it better be really [ __ ] good touch
two thousand seven hundred and fifty
dollars look at this thing
okay it has four buttons the iPhone has
one two three four buttons and costs
less than half that much so for the
privilege of connecting a cable to my
monitor this is a $240 cable anything
that should cables costs $200 it depends
on the type of cable and what the
purpose of that cable is it's a
proprietary custom-made Limu adapter
that has 11 pins on each end and it's
made in America by a tech who really
makes probably about 10 or 20 of them
everyday by hand
well I assume they're really high
quality they're meant to do a very
specific thing yeah but they have really
good shielding involved really high
quality solder points you know the list
can go on as to why that cable can be
expensive threads are really advanced
cameras used by professionals it's made
for people with a lot of experience with
cameras and are looking for a very
specific rig that is very high quality
so red makes you buy an adapter from
their proprietary interface to their
bullsh proprietary cable and you spend
$200 on each end plus $200 for this
dinky ask able to go between them I
understand this correctly red miners are
touch sensitive so you can sit there and
fiddle with all the stuff that's why
that special connections for the
okay but you can also have sling on a
small HD monitor with an HDMI HDS DI
connection and never touch a red monitor
also alright so now do you start joining
together the pieces of my mask and I was
doing a little bit of research over the
weekend and I learned about something
called friction welding basically you
need a dremel and some of your plastic
filament you stick the plastic filament
into the dremel and so the spinning of
that filament when you put it against
another surface will actually get really
hot and it'll melt the filament and then
you can melt it into the plastic seems
to tone your object effectively making
one more little bit of 3d print put it
all together it sounds like a really
cool technique I've never tried it
before I'm going to see if I can use
this to join pieces of my mass together
it's not enough that they have their
fist up your pass charging you $1,500
for a battery and a charger for the
privilege of connecting the battery to
the brain oh you know what it's probably
like $300 Springs it's probably the best
spring the greatest spring 950 dollars
for us handle we've had to be recording
to an external audio recorder for all
the money we spent
it doesn't have an XLR input it bugs me
that he complained about all the
knickknacks he put on the camera and all
the things he had to get for it and how
expensive it was okay I'm gonna point
out all the things that we didn't even
get from the red sword top handle these
top plate use complaining about XLR
adapters look a tiny little XLR adapter
that plugs into the front of the battery
it's a third party battery and it's not
because the red stuff is bad this is our
needs better you don't need all that
stuff unless you are building out a
cinema rig that you are going to take to
a multi-million dollar set and try and
press all the executives that both
accessories that they make you buy
$60,000 in hard drives to store all this
crap on another $20,000 in nvme SSD so
that all of our editors can edit read
footage off of Arnaz at the same time
and what do we get for it 8k videos that
nobody can watch because they don't have
a K displays when you do your research
very usually what you need isn't every
single thing from the store well here's
the other thing so it's like we see this
a lot on with youtubers who get like the
fancy new red cameras out there there
but I think they're making one fatal
mistake which is causing them to
complain about not being able to edit it
on their computer
in fact Linus just recently had a video
where you had to buy $7,000 graphics
card just to edit the footage of the
referees Carter's of red rocket it's a
red rock that's not a graphics okay
thank you I I'm willing to bet
everything that they're shooting at a
really low compression ratio causing a
very large files like and they can't
they can't look at that stuff in real
time even straight playback performance
is abominable it's a nightmare
- did say that he was having a look at
the 8k footage at 1/8 resolution cool
like 1080p right he was saying even that
he wasn't able to get full because the
Congress concession met red files our
processor-intensive they're not red
files are memory intensive because
usually you shoot on low compression
when you're doing high-end stuff but
here on YouTube we're throwing on the
internet and gets encoded in basic
internet compression it doesn't matter
because even our red camera at its
highest compression of like 23 to 1 is a
better image than what you're going to
get when you compress it for you to high
detail environments require very loath
to minimal compression for your footage
everything else crank it a YouTube video
that we put out that we shot with the
red that looks really good nursing for
juice that look great I was 21 22 one so
this is really just a PSA to all red
owners out there who are only uploading
stuff to YouTube between 17 and 22 one
is a reasonable compression ratio to
shoot at on the red yeah also you're
gonna go online to the red store and
you're going to add all those items to
your cart and they show up at your door
and you paid for it all don't then make
a video surprise about how expensive
everything was when you sat there and
you ordered all of it why did we buy two
of them you know they said I'm not doing
this for the final product I'm doing
this for the experience and I want to
make a smooth surface like I've ever
have to join pieces of them all together
I want to know
do that without leaving the scene
unfortunately you're not gonna see the
finished helmet in this video because
this video comes out tomorrow if you do
want to see the finished helmet consider
subscribing it'll help you out following
all the video releases we do and you'll
get to see the finished helmet the
moment it's up hopefully be in a couple
days not quite sure that's where
subscriptions come in alright thanks
take your time do it right do your
research do your right use the right
tools don't cut corners
[Music]